ac
salut à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
filmsactu votre émission consacrée
entièrement au septième art
au sommaire cette semaine des super
héros de l'écurie marvel se réunissent
pour combattre le mal dans the avengers
ducobu revient au cinéma pour hanter nos
vacances tandis que patrick bruel joue
les futurs papas dans le prénom ce qui
est bon en famille c'est qu'on peut tout
se dire
et puis côté sorties vidéo on évoquera
dangerous method le dernier film de
david cronenberg l'ordre et la morale de
mathieu kassovitz et le direct to video
de bruce willis sans compromis des jeux
lego va mais avant on fait le point sur
les meilleures entrées au cinoche aux
états unis et en france avec le box
office de la semaine
le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ne doit pas nous faire
oublier que de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique une couronne vient de
changer deux fronts puisque hunger games
vient enfin de se faire détrôner
chapelle à moi d'hégémonie total par une
comédie donc là que même réalisé par tim
story à qui l'on doit les deux épisodes
des 4 fantastiques
cette comédie met à la fiche le chanteur
chris brown notamment juste derrière on
retrouve the lucky one avec zac efron
heard you explain sortait de la
découverte qui n'existe pas mais qu'il
existe en france ne change pas le
marsupilami d'alain chabat est toujours
premier avec désormais 3 millions
d'entrées suivie de battleship qui a
enregistré six cent mille spectateurs en
une semaine talonnée par blanche neige
qui totalisent 300 mille tickets
non mais je suis pas du tout quoi faire
d'un chien mois la guerre a commencé et
nous sommes désespérément sous arm et
c'est sans nul doute le blockbuster le
plus attendu de l'année avenger est bel
et bien l'aboutissement du travail
accompli par les studios marvel
ces cinq dernières années en sortant un
à un les films consacrés à ses plus
grands super héros
cette fois ci ils sont tous réunis iron
man captain america thor hulk nick fury
oeil de faucon et la veuve noire vont
s'unir pour vaincre loki ch qui a décidé
de [ __ ] le boxon sur terre je choix
donne le metteur en scène a réalisé un
superbe travail et les fans de comics
américains ne seront pas déçus du
résultat avec de l'action en veux tu en
voilà qui mérite vraiment qu'on aille
voir ce film en imax
on va c'est rare
sorti l'été dernier l'élève ducobu est
d'ores et déjà de retour au cinéma
preuve que les aventures de cet enfant
turbulent a séduit les spectateurs qui
vont retrouver la même équipe aux
commandes de cette suite
enfin presque fini les bancs d'école
cette fois ci on passe au soleil à la
plage et au sable fin puisque l'histoire
se déroulera cette fois-ci près de la
mer épatant ducobu si elie semoun remet
le couvert ce n'est plus vraiment le cas
de vincent claude qui a laissé son pull
à rayures jeu des noirs à françois
piette cette nouvelle comédie permet
aussi de découvrir bruno salomone en
animateur de colo et pef qui campe ici
le rôle du papa de ducobu première fois
qu'une demande de l'unps acheter rallier
est-ce que vous avez des idées de
prénoms en a même une assez précise
quand il n'est pas sur scène avec les
[ __ ] ou en promo pour son nouvel
album
patrick bruel fait du cinéma et il est
de retour cette fois ci avec une comédie
sociale ou un couple va se retrouver
face aux critiques de leurs proches
lorsqu'il décide de révéler le prénom de
leur futur enfant
ça vous a pas plu à leur profil s'en
suit alors toute une série d' orgueil la
d2 problème remis sur la table qui
risque de faire sourire les spectateurs
bon stop reprenons avec calme et
sérénité
c'est mr fabre est
devos après les sorties ciné place au
bac vidéo avec pour commencer le
dangerous method le dernier film de
david cronenberg qui a décidé de parler
du thème de l'hystérie on retrouve un
jeune femme souffrante keira knightley
qui campe ici le rôle de sabrina
spielrein tandis que michael fassbender
et viggo mortensen vont s'occuper de son
cas en incarnant respectivement khartoum
et sigmund freud i want you to pas riche
mais un film réussi et touchant qui
révèlent une fois encore le talent de
cronenberg jasper est d'accord
sorti au cinéma en novembre dernier
l'ordre et la morale de mathieu
kassovitz a fait un bide monumental de
gouvernement n'a pas l'intention de
laisser commandé par une bande de force
fidèle à sa réputation d'enfant terrible
du cinéma français
le réalisateur n'a pas hésité à faire
savoir sa colère et prend sa revanche
cette semaine pour la sortie de son film
en blu ray et dvd
c'est quoi que tu peux plus revenir en
arrière
une belle occasion de se plonger dans
cette histoire inspirée de faits réels
puisque retraçant la prise d'otage des
gendarmes sur l'île d'ouvéa en
nouvelle-calédonie en avril 1988 sujet
choc pour un film poignant
depuis quelques années maintenant bruce
willis a du mal à se trouver de bons
rôles et même si celui qu'il joue dans
sans compromis qui sort cette semaine en
blu ray et dvd est fidèle à sa
philosophie
le film n'a pas eu le droit à une sortie
au cinéma c'est d'autant plus étonnant
que le casting composé de forrest
whitaker et malin akerman qu'on avait vu
d'ailleurs dans watchmen mérite vraiment
qu'on s'intéresse à cette histoire de
tueur à gages psychotique
une actu c'est terminé pour cette
semaine on se donne rendez-vous dans
sept jours exactement pour vous parler
des prochaines sorties ciné et vidéos
il y aura du sexe avec american pie 4 de
l'angoissé avec la cabane dans les bois
et encore une comédie française avec des
pressions et des potes avec fred testot
et jonathan lambert bonne semaine et bon
film à tous